the hardest thing is practicing in the
arena instead of at your practice
facility you know it's the only time all
year where somebody tells you okay
you're not allowed to practice in your
practice facility you know so you
practice at the arena and like 500 media
members are going to come in for the
last five minutes or the first five
minutes well you have to put on like a
fake practice in the finals where it's
like all right guys do three-man weave
or you know like what are we doing and
it's crazy you're playing for the
biggest prize you know biggest games of
your life and you're not allowed to
follow your routine and you guys as
individual players can't get your usual
shooting time on the practice floor
you've got six Hoops six empty Hoops in
the main Arena there's only two Hoops
you can't do the same routine it's to me
it's nuts but it's all part of the media
obligations that both teams have